بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسوله
الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان
لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له هو يتولى
الصالحين واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعدهاد
المعاد في هدي خير العباد
اسلام ابن قيم الجوزيه رحمه الله
‏asades
are beond what it is
inl
people
هذا
مسلم ان يتعلمه وان يقراه
له مختصرات
له مختصرات كثيره
فله مختصر
من
محمد
اي ابن عبد الله التميمي اختصره
وله مختصر لبعض علماء
اي المملكه مثل الشيخ محمد صالح العثيمين
وله مختصرات كثيره الكتاب نفسه الاصلي
طويل جدا وفيه مباحث قد لا يفقهها كثير من
الناس لكن اذا قرا الاصل
ومرور الكرام عن المباحث التي يبحثها من
حيث يعني الروايات والرجال وما اشبه مما
قد لا يفهمه الا المتخصص
فانه يستفيد كثيرا كثيرا كثيرا فهذا كتاب
في غايه الاهميه لماذا؟
لانه اراد رحمه الله تعالى ان ياخذ هذا
الكتاب
وان يجعله
يعني ان يجعله
صندوقا لجميع احوال رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم فجميع الاحاديث
وجميع الاحوال
وسيره النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم وكل
الفوائد التي تؤخذ منه وكان يعلمها
ابن القيم رحمه الله فانه جعل زبده علمه
وكل ما في جعبته من علمه عن رسول الله صلى
الله عليه وسلم في هذا الكتاب
والذي يقرا الاحاديث الكثيره مثلا يقرا في
الكتب الست يقرا في صحيح البخاري يقرا في
صحيح مسلم هذه كتب متوسعه الانسان قد يضيع
فيها هذه تحتاج الى تخصص انه الواحد يفتح
صحيح البخاري ويقرا
لان في بعض ال الروايات وبعض الاحاديث
ما يظهر لغير المتخصص التناقض
وابن القيم رحمه الله عالج هذه الاشياء
اشياء علاجا شافيا كافيا ان شاء الله في
هذا الكتاب زاد المعاد فانا اشبه هذا
الكتاب زاد المعاد اشبهه بتفسير ابن كثير
واشبهه بتفسير ابن جرير الطبري كما فعل في
كتاب الله سبحانه وتعالى فعل ابن القيم
رحمه الله في سنه رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم بوك
‏can
that home
so important because
person
let
you takeحاري and
صحيح البخاري
الامام البخاري رحمه الله
صحيح البخاري 17 years
are special
صحيح
this
ابن القيم رحمه الله
صلى الله عليه
‏and made
of
a single line of coherent
coherent
understanding of the prophet
سنه and so person who
the original
is really thick
‏There's a lot of stuff in there that is
for schar to and a lot of the regular
people understand
are
السلام
زاد المعاد
محمد بن عبد الله التميميز
المدن
القمز
[Silence]
ابن القيم رحمه
ان شاء الله
اسباب شرح الصدور
اسباب شرح الصدر
ر
[Silence]
‏What we see most of our time most of
the day things that would make a person
stand up on
is now something is noral
right even if you turn on aion
just any tevion
there will be thousand of seual su
that are passed off innocent it's not ry
because the envelope has been pushed
‏ar
isl et and havees have we have
all through all ours
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
اسباب شرح الصدر
قران
سه الرعد
الله سبحانه وتعالى
سبحانه وتعالى
انزل من السماء ماء ماء
فسالت اوديه بقدرها
فاحتمل السيل زبدا رابيا
الله سبحانه وتعالى
‏in
would all
of the top of
soران
سهable
قران الله سبحانه وتعالى
سه الرعد
الرعد
اوكي
flish
رش
[Silence]
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏seeds grow grapes and some seeds grow
pomegranates and some seeds grow apples
and some seeds grow datem palms and some
seeds grow on and on and on he mention
and that is what the ques to us we each
have our own biological directions that
we go to things that we things we
are drawn to andر
‏andet
that you know kind of covered our hearts
when itetes that rust and reaches thee
and reaches the seed that is found in
the heart we flourish and we bear
different kind of fr all of them work
towards the same work towards the same
go which is to nourish which
‏place aweer place a place of peace a
place of digity a place where person
الله سبحانه وتالى place
of سبحانه وتالى
اللهر
سبحانه وتعالى
انزل من السماء ماء فسالت اوديه بقدرها
فاحتمل السيل زبدا رابيا
سبحانه وتعالى
‏and down
and gather up in the right well the over
time have accumulated a lot of filth
correct people pass by in the valley
people don't cl on mountains usually
usually they are passing in the valley
and so there is dung from
‏people theirage all kinds
and say
that isain
down in your mind this with me he is the
one who sends down from above and it
colcts in the
when
‏enough
if there is enough
it will to become what aam
right
thatam becom strong enough it could even
become as strong as a river but the
point is is that thisam that gathers in
the
it will begin to uproot and pick up all
of the filth that is in that valy
كذلك يضرب الله الحق والباطل
الله سبحانه وتعالى
فاما الزبد فيذهب جفاء واما ما ينفع الناس
فيمكث في الارض كذلك يضرب الله الامثال
سبحانه وتعالى
that all
of theam
will be done away with and flushed away
and
[Silence]
ابن القيم رحمه
رانر
[Silence]
‏from things up
our lives
more a person heart
as much as his heart can to capacity
the more a person his heart and the more
he floods his heart with the
with theران
‏more
up and out fl out
and what will in the heart aure
that will be of benit and ofqu to the
will
this
شرح الصدر
الله سبحانه وتعالى شرح الصدور ايش هو شرح
الصدر؟ الشرح هو الفتح ان تفتح الشيء
والصدر والقلب في القران مترادفان كثيرا
من الوقت صح ولا لا؟ يعني الذي يوسوس في
صدور الناس ايش يعني صدور الناس؟ يعني
قلوب الناس صح ولا لا؟
وكذلك
يذكر الله سبحانه وتعالى القلب والفؤاد
والصدر
كل هذه الثلاثه تعني القلب
في قول من اقوال العلماء
الصدر قد يطلق الصدر ويراد به ايش؟ القلب
يطلق الفؤاد ويراد به ايش؟ القلب يطلق
القلب ويراد به ايش؟ القلب لكن
لاختلاف المقامات يتخير الله سبحانه
وتعالى الالفاظ
وهذه مساله دقيقه بلاغيه
بحسب السياق على كل حال شرح الصدر يعني
شرح القلب فتح القلب
ان يفتح القلب فيدخل نور الله ويدخل الغيث
من كتاب الله
فيصل الى جذور هذا القلب فينبت وياتي
بما يحتمله هذا القلب وما فيه من خير فاذا
دخل نور الله في القلب فانه بقدر ما يدخل
من نور يخ يخرج من فاكهه
ويخرج من خير ويخرج من ايمان وهكذا افهمتم
القصه هذه هذه من اهم المهمات يقول الله
سبحانه وتعالى فمن يرد الله ان يهديه
يشرح صدره للاسلام
ايش يعني هذا يعني يفتح قلبه لقبول نور
الله سبحانه وتعالى ومن يرد ان يضله يجعل
قلبه
ضيقا حر ح ح ح ح حرجا كانما يصعد في
السماء
ماشي
so this here is very important
because
‏things you
moreرa
[Silence]
ران
‏my
videos
my
ch
because at first the want
illness inside and any doctor knows when
you first start to
‏med the body will react in aent way why
because the illness is fighting back it
doesn't want it doesn't want the medic
you understand what
the more you taking the medere
bec until
you are
right you have to
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه
‏arriv
[Silence]
‏will have a river of fire and a river
of
the fire will appear feel smell taste
everything ‏real burning lava fire
not just watching it on a
television it is vivid
and the water will pure and pr andol and
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان الدجال ياتي وان معه ماء ونارا
فاما ما يراه الناس
ماء فهي فهو نار تحرق
واما ما يراه الناس ما واما ما يراه الناس
نارا فماء بارد عذب
فمن وقع منكم في شيء من ذلك فليقع في
النار يعني في ناره فانه ماء عذب زلال
هيك جاء بمعنى الحديث عن الرسول صلى الله
عليه وسلمجالine
[Silence]
perceive to
‏fire
and you prop
anyol
[Silence]
‏you havey alles
you havey what eyes are tell you you
havey what yours are tell you you have
defy what your
touch and is telling you all of your s
you are looking at fire
صلى الله عليه وسلم more
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
more
eyes and
that's what that means
and this is
that we are going through today the
fitna of the prud
‏All this around neon distraction right
to us all occupied
until we out of time and
notou ours all
of
‏and jaz to you occupied.
And so when you got everything there,
right? You got music and you got little
funny tiks and you got this gu fall and
a duck play in the piano and you got and
you just it's only minutes. Oh, it's
only 15 second video only. Before you
know it, the entire day is gone. You go
to sleep your heart is filled with
filth.
‏Why you have no thousand
of suggestive mat
go
against face
and the more you
more the light ofete
in that heart so not question how do
‏I need
رانر
[Silence]
صلاه
we haveay
foray
to people
oh myur my backur my head hurs i can't
stand that long sickly this that ‏And
then as soon as the prayer is done, what
happens? We stand outside in the parking
lot for 3 hours and we chit chat about
nonense.
Right? Why? Because we have no tolerance
for the Quran. We have no tolerance for
the sunah. We hear it a little bit and
com and say that's enough. Get up. Go
walk away. Come on. Leave this.
Don't worry about this. Get out of here.
Get out of here. Go. Go cch so and so.
‏you listen to lat you this before
my
الذين اتخذوا دينهم لعبا ولهوا وغرتهم
الحياه الدنيا
وذكر به ان تبسل نفس بما كسبت ليس لها من
دونه ولي ولا ليس لها من دون الله ولي ولا
شفيع وان تعدل كل عدل لا يؤخذ منها اولئك
الذين ابسلوا بما كسبوا لهم شراب من حميم
وعذاب اليم بما كانوا يكفرون هكذا يقول
الله سبحانه وتعالى
صحيح البخاري
مدينه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
was
kind
of them left the
arrived right theyaving
saw the صلى الله عليه وسلم
some
prop صلى الله عليه
‏in and
the way they sat behind the circle
because he was toy to make a scene of
trying to get into the circle and the
third one was more bold heed himself in
and the companions moved over and let
him sit in and so the prophet
اتدرون ما شان هؤلاء الثلاث
الله سبحانه وتعالى
اما الاول فاعرض فاعرض الله
الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتالى
استحيا فاستحي الله منه
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
واما الثالث
فاوى الى الله فاواه الله
سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
‏How much med
before
you
and that's another deing with now you
‏mention statistics mention that theage
theage atttion span of anage
male or female right now you know with
the age bracket of about 10 to 30 do you
know what the what the what the
what the attention span is the average
atttion span what atttion span
يا ريت واللهنا
في نعمه
‏American in time
after 10 seconds they people interest
around that first 10 seconds to give you
glam and suck you in quick because with
that 10 seconds they
and then now they come to us in
‏noting because we need to do this and
we need to do that. We need to change
the way that we approach them, right? We
need to add a little music here. We need
to add a little this here. We need to
add a little zest here. Right?
We need to approach them on different
platforms.
So they're on Instagram now. ‏So we know
to go on Instagram. Instagram is 99%
garbage. And you have to walk through
all of that to get to the 1% of good.
Right? It's putting a back of a bar
right. This is this is what we deing
with now.
And so the point is that you have a
simple mathematical equation.
‏and how much
more
ابن القيم رحمه
ابن القيم رحمه الله
يقول ان قلب ابن ادم
مثل عرش الرحمن
كيف
يقول كما ان العرش
من اجل ان يليق لان يستوي عليه الرحمن
ويكون لائقا لذلك
لابد ان يكون اعظم واطهر خلائق الله
فكذلك قلب الانسان
من اجل ان تستوي على قلبه اسماء الله
وصفات الله ومعرفه
لابد ان يكون هذا القلب من اطهر واعظم
القلوب
قلبا هكذا يقول ابن القيم رحمه
الله
[Silence]
was
apprate الله
الله
ثم استوى على العرش
[Silence]
سبحان
‏And so if you want you Allah't
you will notble
رحمه
‏more
sin dir the mir be
and you look into the mir not
anyore
and mind in the blank
‏more
[Silence]
اخواني واخواتي في الله هذا من اهم الامور
في مساله
السلوك والقلوب
القلب كالمراه
كلما اقترفت سيئه
فان هذه فان هذا المراه
يعلوه الصداء ويعلوه الران
كلا بل ران على قلوبهم
ما كانوا يكسبون
فاذا علاه الران
نظرت في هذه
المراه فلم ترى الحق رايت اشياء واشباحا
ليست هي ما هي ما ليست هي حقيقه الدنيا
صرت ترى ما تريد ان تراه من من هوى نفسك
وكلما عملت الخير واستغفرت
وقرات القران ودخل قلبك الوحي فان قلبك
يسقل بذلك
وهذا هذه المراه تصف
فتنظر في المراه فترى الحق
فترى الحق حقا
‏So
is not of
the heart it is an issue of once we open
the heart what do we do with
it
and I will finish with this ان شاء الله
ابن القيم رحمه الله also
كافر من من الكفار
اكثر ذكرا في ران
[Silence]
فرعون
موسى عليه لام
ابن القيم رحمه
‏insران
[Silence]
الله فرعون
‏will
you
[Silence]
‏You are not
there is a monstering behind somewh in
there.
You need to find him and you need to
address him.
هذا ونسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يوفقني
واياكم
ل
الخير كله اللهم انا نسالك باسمائك الحسنى
وصفاتك العلى ان ترينا الحق حقا وان
ترزقنا اتباعه وان ترينا الباطل باطلا وان
ترزقنا اجتنابه اللهم انا نرجوك باسمائك
الحسنى وصفاتك العلى ان تعلمنا ما ينفعنا
وان تنفعنا بما علمتنا اللهم انا نرجوك يا
ربنا يا رب السماوات والارض ان تجعل
القران ربيع قلوبنا ونور صدورنا وجلاء
احزاننا وذهاب همومنا وصل اللهم وسلم على
نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين وبارك الله فيكم.
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر